en julio de 2014 en el este de Ucrania
se había desatado un conflicto armado
cuatro meses atrás y aún así el vuelo
mh17 de Malasia Airlines que había
despegado de amsterdam Era uno de los
160 vuelos de Aviación civil autorizados
para sobrevolar la zona un accidente o
quizás una agresión intencionada estaba
destinada a ocurrir el 17 de julio un
misil derribó el mh17 en doniesc
territorio ucraniano controlado por los
separatistas apoyados por Rusia en el
accidente murieron los 298 pasajeros y
la tripulación incluidos 80 niños que el
accidente se produjera en medio de una
zona de conflicto activo complicaría
considerablemente la investigación pero
no estaba todo perdido como el vuelo
despegó en amsterdam la investigación se
encargó a un equipo de autoridades
neerlandesas junto con funcionarios de
Australia Bélgica Malasia y Ucrania las
naciones más afectadas por el incidente
el equipo conjunto de investigación exa
los registros de teléfonos móviles redes
sociales los relatos de los Testigos y
los restos del avión entre las pistas
más importantes un trozo de metralla en
forma de mariposa extraído del cuerpo de
una víctima que reveló el tipo y el
modelo de arma utilizada 15 meses
después los investigadores concluyeron
que una ojiva de fabricación rusa
lanzada con el sistema de misiles ruso
Book fue lanzada desde la parte del este
de Ucrania controlada por los Rebeldes
prorrusos para derribar el avión dos
años después en mayo de 2018 Australia y
Países Bajos responsabilizaron o
públicamente a Rusia por el accidente
una acusación basada en el sistema de
misiles descubierto que pertenecía a una
brigada rusa con base en la ciudad de
kursk en uno de los apartamentos de la
brigada número 53 se ven varios
vehículos entre ellos los telar Rusia ha
rechazado enérgicamente las acusaciones
alegando que tiene motivaciones
políticas el kremlin insiste en que el
misil fue disparado desde ucraniano y
que los misiles Book en cuestión habían
sido retirados de su servicio años antes